♪ ♪
>> Dana: HELLO, EVERYONE.
I AM DANA PERINO WITH DAN
BONGINO, MARIE HARF,
JESSE WATTERS, AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
VISIT "THE FIVE" ."
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
A MUST-SEE TV MOMENT SET FOR
TOMORROW IN WASHINGTON,
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR OF
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN WILL HOLD A NEWS
CONFERENCE AT 9:30 A.M. ON THE
DOT ON THE MUELLER REPORT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT HE MAY ALSO
DO THE SAME, HAVING A PRESS
CONFERENCE.
BARR HAS BEEN FACING SCRUTINY
OVER HIS HANDLING OF THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS A MOMENT WE'VE ALL BEEN
WAITING FOR.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET IT IN THE
MORNING WHETHER YOU LIKE IT OR
NOT.
>> MUST-SEE TV.
>> Dana: DEFINITELY.
EVERYONE'S GOT TO GET UP AND
WATCH.
>> WE ALREADY KNOW THE TOPLINE
CONCLUSION.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION, NO
EFFORT AT COLLUSION OF THE
RUSSIANS TRIED TO COLLUDE IN THE
TRUMPS SAID NO.
MY QUESTION GOING FORWARD, WHAT
THE HECK WAS BOB MUELLER DOING
FOR 675 DAYS.
ANDY McCARTHY HAS A TERRIFIC
PIECE WHERE HE ASKED THIS
QUESTION.
HOW QUICKLY DID MUELLER FIGURE
OUT THERE WAS NO COLLUSION?
THEY HAD TO KNOW NOTHING WAS
GOING ON.
WHAT WAS HE DOING FOR 675 DAYS?
>> Dana: GOING BACK TO A
PREVIOUS SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION.
PATRICK FITZGERALD, U.S.
ATTORNEY, SPECIAL COUNSEL FOR
THE VALERIE PLAME CASE KNEW
IMMEDIATELY.
IT WASN'T KARL ROVE.
MARIE, YOU'RE GOING TO BE UP,
READY.
DO YOU THINK DEMOCRATS, GOING
AFTER BILL BARR, THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S IN IT.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD THING HE'S
GOING TO TAKE QUESTIONS FROM THE
PRESS AND THAT MIGHT TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF THE TENSION OUT OF
IT.
>> Marie: WE'LL SEE.
SOME OF WHAT DAN SAID BARR DID
NOT SAY WAS OF THE MUELLER
REPORT.
HE DID NOT SAY THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN SAID NO THANK YOU AND
THEY TRIED TO COLLUDE.
ONE OF THE THINGS PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING FOR IS HOW MILLER
EXPLAINS THINGS AND EVENTS WE
KNOW HAPPENED AND HOW HE
EXPLAINS THEY DO NOT AMOUNT
TO CRIMINAL COLLUSION.
AS AN AMERICAN AND A HUMAN, I
WANT TO SEE HOW MUELLER DEALS
WITH THE TRUMP TOWER MEETING.
MANAFORT GIVING POLLING TO THE
RUSSIANS.
I THINK THE TWEETS ABOUT THE
MUELLER REPORT HAVE GOTTEN
INCREASINGLY AGGRESSIVE.
IT SEEMS A LITTLE BIT LIKE HE'S
TRYING TO PREEMPT WHAT HE KNOWS
WILL NOT BE UNIFORMLY GOOD
REPORT FOR HIM.
THERE WILL BE THINGS IN THIS
REPORT THAT ARE EMBARRASSING,
THAT ALL OF US SITTING AROUND
THIS TABLE WOULD SAY I NEVER
WOULD'VE DONE THAT IF I WORKED
ON A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
I THINK TRUMP KNOWS THAT AND IS
TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF IT.
>> Dana: OR DO YOU THINK,
JESSE, I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S IN
THE MORE AGGRESSIVE IT BEFORE.
>> Jesse: RELENTLESS WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL FOR A YEAR AND
HALF.
I DON'T THINK ANYTHING IS
CHANGED.
>> Marie: THE LAST COUPLE
DAYS, IT FEELS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
>> Jesse: I'M GLAD YOU ARE IN
TOUCH WITH YOUR FEELINGS.
I THINK 9:30 IS LITTLE EARLY.
IT WOULD GIVE ME MORE TIME TO GO
TO THE GYM AND DIGEST.
I THINK WITH THE REPORT COMES
OUT, BUNCH OF LIBERAL MEDIA
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO HOLD UP
EACH PAGE EITHER GOING TO HOLD
IT INTO THE SUNLIGHT TO SEE IF
THEY CAN SEE BEHIND THE
REDACTIONS.
I DO THAT.
THERE IS A SMALL HOPE I CAN THEN
YOU'RE NOT GOING BE ABLE TO DO
THAT.
I THINK WHAT HE SHOULD DO JUST
TO MESS WITH THE PRESS IS GIVE
400 PAGES OF THE WHOLE THING
REDACTED, JUST TO SCREW AROUND
WITH THEM AND SAY FINE.
ONE BIG BLACK DOCUMENT.
DRIVE THEM CRAZY.
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
DEROGATORY INFORMATION IN THERE.
BECAUSE THIS WAS A VERY BRUTALLY
INTRUSIVE EXAM INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE CAMPAIGN.
YOU'RE GOING TO FIND SOME FLAWS
AND THIS WAS UNDERTAKEN BY KIND
OF FEROCIOUS AND -- NOT SINISTER
BUT ANGRY PARTISAN DEMOCRATS
WITH A LOT OF LIBERAL PEDIGREE.
THEY ARE GOING TO FIND SOME
THINGS BUT OVERALL NO
OBSTRUCTION, NO COLLUSION.
I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW SATED IS
GOING TO HANDLE IT BECAUSE THIS
LAST WEEK THEY HAD THE LOWEST
RATED WEEK OF ALL OF 2019.
THEY HAVE A CHOICE TO MAKE.
ARE THEY GOING TO NOW REPORT
REAL NEWS ABOUT SPYGATE OR ARE
THEY GOING TO CONTINUE TO PUSH
FAKE NEWS?
THEY LOST TO THE FOOD NETWORK
LAST WEEK WHICH MEANS PEOPLE
WOULD RATHER WATCH A POT BOIL
THEN WATCH CNN.
>> Dana: YOU LIKE IT WHEN
THESE THINGS HAPPEN, HE LIKE TO
GET THE NEWS AND YOU ALSO LIKE
TO WATCH THE OTHER MEDIA GETTING
THE NEWS.
>> Greg: YES.
DID YOU KNOW WHAT THIS REMINDS
ME OF?
DO YOU REMEMBER APRIL THE
GIRAFFE?
DO YOU REMEMBER HOW LONG WE
WAITED AND WAITED.
IT IS LIKE APRIL THE GIRAFFE
HAVING TWINS AT SEPARATE TIMES.
IT DIDN'T APRIL ALREADY GIVE US
A GIRAFFE THREE WEEKS AGO?
THE MEDIA ARE LIKE MOVIE CRITICS
WHO ARE THE SPOILERS.
THEY ARE LIKE, WE ALREADY KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
DARTH VADER REALLY ISN'T HIS
FATHER.
SORRY, GUYS.
THE MUELLER REPORT TO THE MEDIA
IS LIKE CHEAP TEQUILA IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
YOU TRY IT.
YOU GET DRUNK AND YOU HAVE A
HANGOVER FOREVER BUT THEN YOU
FORGET ABOUT IT AND YOU DO IT
AGAIN.
THEY ARE SETTING THEMSELVES UP
FOR FEELING MISERABLE ON
THURSDAY AFTERNOON.
I WILL AGREE WITH YOU, MARIE.
THERE IS A PRISON OF TWO IDEAS.
HE'S VINDICATED OR IT'S A COVER.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
LITTLE THINGS GOING ON THAT
PEOPLE CAN SINK THEIR TEETH
INTO.
THEY ARE GOING TO SAY NOW WE
KNOW THAT THE RUSSIANS COLLUDED
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT IT WAS A
ONE-WAY STREET, THE TRUMPS
WEREN'T CHASING IT.
SO IT JUST MEANS YOU HAVE TO BE
MORE AWARE OF WHAT THE RUSSIANS
ARE DOING BUT WE ALREADY KNEW
THAT.
IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE RUSSIANS
AND HOW THEY MANIPULATED THE
MEDIA, NOT THE VOTERS.
THE COLLUSION WAS RUSSIA PLAYING
THE MEDIA FOR SUCKERS.
>> Dan: DANA, IT'S INTERESTING
HOW THE STANDARD HAS SHIFTED.
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
NEGATIVE INFORMATION.
OKAY, THE WHOLE JULY 15 JIM
COMEY PRESS CONFERENCE WAS
NEGATIVE INFORMATION ABOUT
HILLARY BUT EVERYONE WANTED TO
MAKE THAT GO AWAY.
IF YOU WERE WHERE THEY WERE
THEREFORE BASICALLY A PROCTOLOGY
EXAM ON YOUR ENTIRE LIFE FOR THE
LAST FIVE YEARS, OF COURSE IT'S
GOING TO BE NEGATIVE.
>> Greg: I HAVE BEEN THERE.
>> Dan: THE QUESTION HERE IS
WAS A CRIME COMMITTED AND THE
ANSWER ACCORDING TO BARR'S
SUMMARY IS NO.
>> Marie: ON OBSTRUCTION, WE
KNOW THAT BOB MUELLER IS GOING
TO LAY OUT A LEGAL CASE FOR
OBSTRUCTION AND A LEGAL CASE
THAT SAYS IT DOESN'T RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF OBSTRUCTION.
>> Dan: WHY DIDN'T HE CHARGE
HIM?
>> Marie: I THINK MUELLER
SHOULD HAVE MADE A DECISION ON
THAT, I AGREE WITH YOU.
HE SHOULD'VE MADE A DECISION AND
NOT LEFT IT TO BARR FOR THERE
WILL BE AN ENTIRE SECTION THAT
SAYS THIS IS WIDELY BELIEVED
DONALD TRUMP COMMITTED
OBSTRUCTION.
WHEN YOU SAY NO OBSTRUCTION --
>> Jesse: VERY HARD TO
OBSTRUCT SOMETHING YOU DIDN'T
DO.
>> Marie: BARR, THAT'S NOT
TRUE LEGALLY.
YOU CAN BE CHARGED WITH
OBSTRUCTION EVEN IF THERE IS NO
UNDERLYING CRIME.
>> Jesse: IF YOU FRAME ME FOR
MURDER AND I SAY STOP, THAT I'M
OBSTRUCTING?
>> Marie: THAT'S NOT EXACTLY
THE LEGAL FRAMING.
BARR SAID MUELLER LAID OUT A
CASE FOR OBSTRUCTION AND AGAINST
AND THEN BARR MADE THE DECISION.
>> Dana: CAN I ASK DAN ONE
OTHER QUESTION.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS DEAFLY
GOING TO GET ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE VERB HE IS
LAST WEEK IN CONGRESSIONAL
TESTIMONY WHICH WAS HE BELIEVES
THERE WAS SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE MUELLER
REPORT GOES INTO THAT FULLY BUT
CERTAINLY IF YOU OPEN YOURSELF
UP TO A PRESS CONFERENCE, YOU'RE
GOING TO GET QUESTIONS ABOUT IT.
>> Dan: NO SANE PERSON
BELIEVES THAT HE WASN'T SPIED
ON.
NOT ONLY DO WE NOW KNOW THERE
WAS A HUMAN INTELLIGENCE ASSET
USED AGAINST THE TRUMP TEAM ON
THE RECORD.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT A FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SURVEILLANCE COURT,
A SYNONYM FOR SPYING FOR
RATIONAL PEOPLE, USED A WARRANT
AND THREE RENEWALS TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP TEAM.
GETTING INTO THE EUPHEMISM GAME
IS THE HEIGHT OF POLITICAL
IMMATURITY.
JUST TAKE THE L.
U SPIED ON THE TRUMP TEAM.
ADMIT IT.
DROP THE LOSS AND CUT THE
EUPHEMISMS BE 21.
HE WAS AN UNDOCUMENTED INFORMAN
INFORMANT.
EVERY SANE PERSON KNOWS THAT THE
GUY IS A SPY.
>> Dana: NO MATTER WHAT, THE
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS,
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, SHE
SAID SHE IS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
JUST LAST WEEK SHE SAID THAT.
PELOSI SAID WE ARE NOT THERE YET
BUT DO YOU THINK TOMORROW AT
9:31 THAT DEMOCRATS WILL SAY
THEY HAVE A CASE?
>> Jesse: THEY HAVE TO BE
PRETTY FAST READERS TO DO THAT
BUT I'M SURE THEY'RE GOING TO
TRY TO MAKE SOME SORT OF HAY OUT
OF IT.
THINK ABOUT HOW THE SPYING
HAPPENED.
THEY COOKED UP THE INTELLIGENCE,
LEAKED IT TO THE PRESS, THEN
TOOK THE FAKE NEWS REPORTS AND
USED IT TO GET A WIRE TO SPY.
I CAN TELL YOU NOW WE KNOW THIS.
I CAN TELL YOU WHAT WE DO KNOW.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND ALL THEIR
OFFICIALS, THEY ARE NOT AS
NERVOUS AS THE OBAMA OFFICIALS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE WHEELS OF
JUSTICE ARE STARTING TO SPIN
AGAINST THEM NOW.
>> Marie: I LOOK VERY CALM
RIGHT NOW.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
I HAVE BEEN OCULAR MIGRAINE AND
I WOULD LIKE TO BLAME IT ON JOHN
RICH FOR FORCING ME TO DRINK
WHISKEY.
I CANNOT SEE OUT OF MY LEFT EYE.
EVERYONE WHO HAS OCULAR
MIGRAINES KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING